Two weeks ago, the rule was simple:
never boil your broccoli, because
heat destroys the enzyme that
makes its most important molecule.
Today, I am going to tell
you to cook your tomatoes.
And the reason those two
statements do not contradict
each other is the whole
point of this video.
A raw tomato is not the
best version of a tomato.
Cooking it
The thing everyone tells you destroys
nutrients, makes its most valuable
molecule several times easier
for your body to actually use.
The red in a tomato is a
pigment called lycopene.
It belongs to the same family as the
beta carotene that makes carrots orange.
But inside a raw tomato,
lycopene is not free.
It sits inside structures
called chromoplasts,
bound into a matrix of
protein and membrane.
Your digestion is not good
at breaking that open.
Eat a raw tomato, and much of
the lycopene passes through you
still locked inside the fragments
of plant cell it arrived in.
Heat does three things to that.
First, it ruptures the cell walls.
Mechanical release.
The pigment is no longer trapped behind
cellulose your enzymes cannot cut.
Second, it denatures the proteins
holding the pigment in place, so
the molecule comes free rather
than staying bound to a structure.
Third, and this is the
interesting one, heat
changes the shape of the molecule itself.
In a raw tomato, most
lycopene is a straight,
rod-like form, called the trans isomer.
Heat bends it into cis isomers, and that
bent shape packs far more easily into
the micelles that carry fat-soluble
molecules across your intestinal wall.
Straight molecules stack badly.
Bent ones fit.
So the same amount of
lycopene, cooked, reaches
your bloodstream in
much larger quantities.
In controlled human studies, lycopene
from tomato paste was absorbed several
times better than lycopene from an
equivalent portion of fresh tomatoes.
There is a second multiplier.
Lycopene is fat-soluble, so without fat,
there are no micelles waiting for it.
Cooking tomatoes in olive
oil is not just flavour.
It completes the delivery system.
Same mechanism we covered with avocado.
The fat is not the nutrient.
The fat is the vehicle.
Now follow it past the intestine.
Absorbed lycopene is packed
into chylomicrons, enters
the lymphatic system, and
reaches your bloodstream.
From there, it transfers
into your lipoproteins.
And this is where it gets specific.
Lycopene concentrates
inside LDL particles.
That matters.
Because the first step in
arterial plaque is not LDL itself.
It is LDL becoming oxidised
inside the artery wall.
An oxidised LDL particle
is what a macrophage
swallows uncontrollably
to become a foam cell.
Lycopene riding inside that particle
sits exactly where the damage starts.
It also builds up in tissue.
The liver, the adrenal glands,
the testes and the prostate
hold the highest
concentrations in the body.
So what does the evidence say?
Here it splits, and I want to be careful.
On observational data, it is consistent.
People with higher lycopene
intake, and more importantly
higher lycopene measured in
their blood, show lower rates
of cardiovascular disease
across many populations.
Meta-analyses of those studies agree.
On randomised trials, it is thinner.
Supplementing isolated lycopene
has not reliably reproduced
the benefit seen in
people who eat tomatoes.
That gap usually means one of two things.
Either the whole food matters
more than the single molecule,
or the association was never fully causal.
We do not yet know which.
On prostate cancer, be sceptical
of what you have heard.
The claim was strong in the
nineteen nineties, and has
been steadily downgraded
as better studies arrived.
Regulators now describe that
evidence as very limited.
Mechanism.
Strong.
Population data, consistent.
Isolated supplement trials, disappointing.
So, four rules.
One.
Cook them.
Sauce, roasted, stewed, or paste.
The processed form is genuinely
the better source here,
which is rare enough to
be worth saying out loud.
Two.
Cook them in oil.
Without fat, the lycopene
has no way across.
Three.
Tomato paste is the most concentrated
lycopene source in an ordinary kitchen.
One spoonful carries more
than several fresh tomatoes.
Four.
Keep some raw, because cooking
does cost you vitamin C.
This is a real trade, not a free upgrade.
Cooked for lycopene, raw
for vitamin C, and eat both.
Two quick notes.
Very high long-term intake can
tint the skin faintly orange.
It is harmless, and it reverses.
And if you have reflux, tomato
is a common trigger, which has
nothing to do with lycopene and
everything to do with acidity.
None of this was really about a tomato.
It was about a molecule that is
present but unavailable, and the fact
that how you prepare your food
decides which of those two it is.
So which molecule should we follow next?
Write a food and an organ in the comments,
and we will take it apart, cell by cell.